what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 7 of the Django tutorials where we
left off we created a user registration
page and now what we want to do is allow
for our users to notice right when
something has happened so when they log
in or when they register they should
just be logged in and see that they've
been logged in and then also when things
go wrong they should see like errors and
know what went wrong that sort of thing
so to do that what we're gonna do is
mostly inside of our templates I'm
trying to think well we do have a couple
of things we'll have to pass in views
but for most of our work today we're
going to be working in our templates so
first of all let's go into views and do
what I was soon so we'll go to the
tippity-top here and all we need to
import here is the messages from Django
so a lot of web frameworks are going to
give you some way to like send unique
messages to your users so there's just
so many times when you want there to be
some way to pop up a little message for
all sorts of reasons but maybe we log in
register hit some sort of error whatever
okay so with Django that's no different
we're gonna say from Django dot contrib
imp or messages not error messages why
did you do that to me
messages jerk okay
so once we've got the messages then we
can come down to say register for
example user form dot save you might say
something like this messages dot success
and this would be to the specific
request so this will always go to the
exact user that's supposed to get this
message so you could add something that
would be like site wide and you could do
it through messages by just like always
passing a message but
if you want to have some sort of site
wide notification system like maybe
you're doing updates or you're getting
tossed or something like that
and you want to just notify your users
that something is up then I would I'm
not sure I would use messages I would
probably put something in the header
file that just kind of sits below the
nav bar or something like this this is
really for specific users but you could
use it for whatever you want I suppose
anyways requests and then we can say
something like this we could say a new
account created and then the account
will be oh we need to give it the
username I I knew we were gonna use it
but anyway we'll say username equals
form dot
cleaned data get username username and
anytime you have something like this
like form dot cleaned data we if you if
you want to know exactly what's going on
you could just literally type that in or
give with form and then let's see let's
Google cleaned whoops
cleaned data I'm hoping to eventually
get here oops let me go back to where we
were hopefully yeah normalizing it to a
consistent format I'm guessing I'm
trying to decide on't actually know if
they'll remove like crazy characters and
stuff like that I am kind of curious I
wish it would tell you exactly what that
method does when it cleans cleaned data
clean data also cleaning it normalizing
it to a consistent format I'm assuming
it's not like escaping for like SQL
stuff I'm guessing that models or
handles that on its own I am curious I'm
not actually seeing the answer here each
form is responsible for validating but
also cleaning it
I would really like to know clean data
huh I would be curious to know more I've
really thought I was couldn't find the
answer to that but no anyway that's just
general you are going to almost always
clean data then get user name so this
will be the users user name and then
we'll say request new account created
and then we're going to give the user
name so at this point will this all this
does is the messages now exists like
there we're not delivering that message
in any way it just exists okay so it's
gonna be as stored and then later we're
gonna have to like retrieve these
messages and basically the messages will
only exist initially and then once
they're served they're gone so anyway so
we'll say new account created and then
username for example and then coming
down here possibly here for like formed
error messages rather than print formed
error messages or whatever we could
instead say messages dot error request
and then literally the exact same thing
I kind of guys like each on my neck I
think what I'd like to do actually is
make this an F string and then come this
because I'd like to see the key as well
so here well just the error message will
literally be the key : and then the
value so we'll get all of the
information space there okay
good enough and then just for the record
there's like success info debug error
and I think warning or something like I
think I'm thinking that's that's the one
anyways we'll cover those here in a
minute
and you can handle them in all different
ways and again I'll cover that as well
somewhere view is completed so now what
we want to do is the this message is
getting passed it is now a part of the
request but we have to still access that
request and say display that message and
the way I would like to display that
message is if we go to materialized CSS
comm and we go to G whoops JavaScript
and come on down to two hosts so if I
click this button it shows you an
example of a toast like this is it
and we were just like one of these two
pop-up with the message that we're
trying to give to our user so as you can
see I'm trying to see if there's like a
really basic one I think I might just
toast and this one just has caught
callbacks and stuff anyway it's just a
script where you pass M toast yeah
basically this right here so inside of
script tags you'll pass that but I'll
show you guys how we're gonna do it
anyways so now we want to do is so we
could do this inside of register here
but we probably actually want to handle
four messages site-wide right because
the messaging system is for everywhere
on your website so instead actually I
would handle for them inside of the
header h2 ml file so likely likely
within the container you might opt to
not do it in the container I'm not
really sure where I would rather have it
to be honest with you guys I'm gonna
start with it
in because I almost don't I think I
might actually do it outside the
container I don't it really doesn't
matter it's going to depend on what
probably really mostly on what type of
device your website's going to be used
on most but with the container like full
size the you know most of the content
sits in the more like the center so
there'd be plenty of space for the for
the message to pop up top right
it's outside of the containers not going
to cover anything so I think that's
actually what I'm going to do anyway so
the way that we can do this is first
with an if statement so we're gonna just
ask if messages so if there are any
messages so then we have two and if now
if there are messages we want to iterate
over the message so for message in
messages and then don't forget to end
your for now we want to display the
message so this is just script script
and what we will say is M actually it's
a capital m dot toast and then there's
like a bunch of these parameters that we
can pass into here so I'm just gonna do
this so HTML this is the actual HTML
that you want to pass and in this case
it's just going to be the message then
there's all kinds of things that we can
add so for example you could say classes
and this will be classes as in your your
CSS so for example I could say blue and
then you also can round it so I'll say
blue and round it so it won't be a
square it would be kind of like a little
rounded message then we can also add a
display length this is how long will the
message show so and this is in
milliseconds so this will be two seconds
mmm yeah I think that's good enough what
we will do is test it and in fact let me
first make sure toasts work at all so
I'm gonna just paste one in real quick
come over here refried on't really want
to do that hold on we come over here
Oh interests oh because there's no
message so that was our cut because this
message variable doesn't exist so
toasted
okay now if we were fresh there's your
you know your blue rounded toast and you
can dismiss them by like swiping them
away otherwise
just disappears in two seconds you also
can somewhere someone in here they did
have a dismiss maybe this let's see if
this has it i omit 1000 that's call back
there toast with action how about this
there you go so you could you could use
like a button to dismiss it as well if
you wanted but i'm not gonna do that
we're just gonna have it show up for a
period of time okay so the toast is
working now
cool now the thing is i really would
like to have these different like your
class blue that's the background well
wouldn't it be nice to have like
information and air or aryl error
warning that kind of stuff the different
colors right depending on the severity
of the message you also might want to
display it for a different amount of
time based on the importance of that
message so the way that we're gonna do
that i don't think i am i don't see any
benefit to writing this one out so i'm
gonna copy pasta this from the
text-based version of the tutorial link
is in the description so just grab that
I just don't I just think it'd be a
waste of our time there's really no new
logic here so anyway let's paste that in
so now we have handling for success info
warning and error I'm pretty sure there
is a debug but anyway good enough cool
so now it handles for precisely what
type of error it is because so we've got
like success and info so we could come
over to our views dot PI account created
so success and then maybe let's do a
messages info when someone logs in so
messages dot info logged in to user you
are now logged in as username maybe no :
cool
okay cool so now let's come over to our
website and register a new user will do
semtex 3 mana fat-fingered that one
let's try again
register I get out of my way
dang it it got in my way anyway they
were there one was green and one was
blue maybe I could hit never and that
wouldn't have happened anyway
great so that worked out pretty well the
next thing I'd like to do is just show a
different looking navigation bar once
the user has logged in so the next thing
we're gonna do is come back to our
header HTML and we'll come over to our
nav bar which is all right here so we
would still I mean the logo should stay
the same home button can stay the same
but really here this should be different
depending on these two things should be
different depending on if the user is
logged in or not so what we can ask is
if user dot is authentic thing then to
kated if user is authenticated we show
something else and then we will end
whoops and our if statement so I'm just
going to take this tab it over copy come
down here oops
tab that over copy paste okay so if the
user is authenticated third logged in
they don't need to register anymore they
might have I don't know an account page
so maybe head to slash account and then
we could even call this their username
so I think user dot username would
probably work here I don't really
actually know I think that's probably
good enough and then here rather than
login it should be logout
gowns maybe we'll capitalize that L as
well okay all right so now let us head
back on over let's refresh okay cool
so now it shows the username and log out
because this user is logged in now we
don't actually have logout handling yet
we will probably do that in the next
tutorial because first I want to talk
briefly about handling now for all of
this so as like part of the reason why
we're using these templates is so stuff
doesn't take up so much space and our
header is actually pretty darn simple
but as we continue to have like logic
like all this it serves taking up a lot
of space so how do we fix for that well
what we can do instead is have our nav
bar for example in its own file and we
can have like messages in its own file
in their own file so the way that we're
going to do that is we'll come over here
to templates and then I like to put a
new directory inside a templates called
includes because you might have a lot of
templates and you might have a lot of
includes so what I'm gonna do now is I'm
just going to copy home and I'm gonna
paste that into includes and then I'm
gonna call this one navbar nav for OK
and then I'm gonna come back into here
and it includes and let's open up navbar
so inside of here
and in fact actually I'm pretty sure
with includes you don't need block
content we're gonna find out I'm pretty
sure you don't
so for navbar let's just take the navbar
code so from nav to nav cut paste save
that and then where our navbar used to
be we're going to add a quick message
here that just says include and then it
is the path to the navbar starting at
templates so main includes navbar dot
HTML okay so we'll come over here
refresh refresh refresh okay looks the
same no difference okay but we've saved
a lot of space let's do the same exact
for messages so I'm gonna come over here
I'm gonna copy/paste I'm gonna change
this to messages we're gonna open up
messages delete messages we'll come over
to header and we will cut messages paste
messages and then come over here and in
fact actually let's just copy and paste
this paste now have bar messages save
that great refresh everything appears to
Oakland log outs not gonna work also
curious why okay I guess it was just
taking a while I was like why didn't any
error so let's just register again
so we'll just register sent decks for PT
one two three four five six seven
register okay cool so we create a new
user that's interesting why did that
happen
is that me it might be because of the
styling cuz we're eventually gonna put a
nav bar over here is that what I've done
alright well we'll have to look into
that later I'm not really too worried
about that anyway for now yeah I wonder
if somehow that's messing up the
container I don't know I'll look into
that for sure anyways now our header is
way cleaner it's only 25 rows and that's
a lot of wasted space actually so we
could just do this or something anyway
much much cleaner much much simpler if
we want to modify something or continue
building on this it's just so much
quicker for us to read you obviously
could go way too far overboard as far as
you know putting things and includes and
stuff like that but I think if you're
gonna get rid of like ten lines of code
or or something like that and like a
bunch of logic and stuff it's just
better to pull it out because you're
also highly likely to start making
mistakes with like div opening and
closing or other tag opening and closing
so this is just one way to much further
simplify things because in your editor a
lot of times you can like if I come over
here and if I highlight this it shows me
where the closing tag is but as your
tags get
really complex it like in sublime it
messes up especially as you start using
the ginger templating and I've seen it
mess up and other things and plus with
your if statements you might close a tag
somewhere and most editors don't
understand what the heck is going on
there so it can get really confusing
really quickly so anyways that's one way
we can clean it up so awesome so at this
point I think I'll leave you guys and
the next tutorial we'll work on logging
out quick shout out to my most recent
channel members AF Richard C ran care
not a fish or cran car een out of it
anyway paren prodigy thank you guys very
much for your support
you guys are awesome and other than that
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
I'm gonna see you guys in another video